welcome to a new game with white the
plate deform Jesus Excel ok let's
transpose back to an e-form setup f4
Bishop g5 lots of choice let's play
Bishop to g5 or f4 f4 looks very very
aggressive 'let let's go F on this
Bishop g5 setup is some quite
interesting against those pilk posts
modern setups it's um a bit more
forceful against them against the pills
with the the knight on f6 the modern
like in this case um against the modern
it is also interesting but it's not um
not as dangerous I regard it as a really
good against the pills it should be I
think good for a bit of an advantage at
least it's it's it's difficult difficult
for black to play ok so him very young
quickly got in five here supported by
the the Queen omnem on a five so how to
proceed he may be a threatens to take
deform could be a could be a problem ok
so maybe let's dead just castle long it
takes on d 494 I will have a useful
temper maybe later with ride b3 and I'm
not sure that he wants to take on d4
anyway as some it opens up the position
and he's not exactly a well-developed
yeah this is a very very cool move just
saying okay I don't care about my
development maybe you can you can play
this may be possible okay if I drop back
on edge for one issue is taking on f4
but like we near 45 just [ __ ] but
after takes on f4 i also have a five of
course i don't think you can take on a
farm E five looks looks really dangerous
than four black opening up the e-file
the only issues if it takes you five
years 95 after night XD 522 would
exchange Queens but blacks position
looks like a swiss swiss cheese after
that one issue here is if you would put
castle exactly it's doing it i can think
about winning upon like tape tape tape
as a techie 595 DDF e95 and then bishop
f6 queen age six winning upon still AM
it's not clear if this is really a
beneficial I also can just play f5
taking and then f5 and g4 and I'm not
sure I want to I want to really am take
this pawn it looks like
look Sam looks a bit crude giving up the
bishop so take a 5 + f5 maybe also moves
like King be one to consider him got
lots of lots of possibilities okay so
take here they're five and I must play a
move at some point I just in 10g 45
attacking directly if he goes 95 then I
will actually take on f6 and take on h6
because I'm the position is more closed
then I can I thank you for two to take
wow really okay yeah maybe you can you
can play that look so really weak but on
h4 is got G form I mean it's not not not
able to open open this up really quickly
okay so I need to clear each 04 for the
Queen and I want to play Knight d2 to
see form regrouping using the weekend
squares here controlling see for now and
one ideas to play h flow of course ya
need to go here now I've got a really
nice bishop on c4 very very good piece
okay so let's try to open up here of
course each five so that don't want to
exchange h5 to isolate the pawn here and
now I intend to just give the exchange
to to open up the position so now should
I do that oh I cannot spend so much time
now
it's probably not completely convincing
unfortunately yeah yeah this is maybe
some some draw for that you should take
from from a positional point of view
Queen a 6am don't want to make draws
really in those games always feels like
I'm robbing the spectators of of
something it sounds still probably a it
still probably would have been the the
correct thing to do should be for now
and and he's seeing this
yeah I've got a little bit of play as
well Queen a8 coming and this was lucky
but I didn't want to make the drum man
position we why I I should have done
done so maybe we've got this coming and
it's a mate of course them I was I was
probably a lost here that's actually a
draw surprisingly rocked it to rook
teacher one book f2 is probably winning
for black and this is a draw funny
enough what was the game sort of
confused here uh yeah I took yeah this
is losses okay what time f6 is a draw
funny yeah of course it cannot go here
of course this is disaster needs to go
here and then we should be three of
course of course I'm threatening made
now and if he takes I have this funny
perpetual aha yeah interesting so in the
game i took here and now he's got some
winning continuation queen deform and
term this this now still queen d 4 but
this losses of course due to the mate
okay it was just the time trouble the
time trouble on issue and this was
probably not so great and i have for
some time to prepare this I don't need
to sacrifice in this serve in this
position
so maybe I'd rather um prepare this or
regroup pieces and this isn't so great
you have interesting chess anyway thanks
for watching